[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
what's going on guys uh it's it's it's a
crazy week man it's a crazy week we we
have
a substantial
amount of stuff to talk about so much
that it seems
it seems kind of unreal a little bit
don't you think they're like
[Music]
Hey listen it's it's a fun for a guy
like me of course
I love it oh yeah you you you you
especially because you know when stuff
like this happens man they they show up
you know people are already talking
about you know it's funny I have a
one-piece shirt on and I've seen like
three episodes of One Piece like
so I'm sorry brother yeah I appreciate
it for coming through it's the attitude
we talk about the past present future
game I got my co-host simply dark
griggity what's going on dirt
uh I've been playing the same thing I
was playing last week I'm still trying
to get through um
uh Gotham Knights um
I saw um some gameplay on your your
video that you just posted on Gotham
Knights oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I've been
trying to get through that so that's
about it man I'm trying to focus on that
finish that one and that's about it
brother
I've been playing I'm trying to get back
into Persona five finish that up I've
also been playing a little bit of loop
hero it's on Game Pass I really
recommend if you guys are like huge
you know charm if you like vampire
survivors but a good game
like this is kind of more of an RPG
this game is and I think it it's
that in Vampire survivors is definitely
built from the same cloth but you know
we we got a a pretty hectic show for you
guys we're gonna talk about you know
with ABK should PlayStation respond
we're also gonna talk about this Black
Panther game you know uh
we'll get to that in a second and we're
gonna talk about obviously Xbox wins the
ABK deal you know they there's uh
they've won the the induction hearing
they haven't won the actual thing where
they can actually get it yet but
don't get it twisted it's just a matter
of time at this point uh you know it is
what it is let me go and get this 20 off
share from hoarder in the Borderlands
actually I really want to play
Borderlands 3 again for some reason
isn't a Russian accent uh do you have a
good Russian accent because I don't
no yeah I don't I don't they come from
our tears but Duran in their own I don't
know that's definitely not a a Russian
accent but you're gonna get the best
thing I can man the best type of accent
I can deliver it's just kind of it
it didn't sound like you were drunk
yeah so that there's there's the only
accent please don't start Super Chat
asking me to to say stuff in accents
you're gonna every ax is gonna sound
like I'm drunk I'm gonna be rolling this
to you guys right now don't do it
all right so let's go we got we got 267
people in the chat definitely hit that
like button we're gonna get on to
PlayStation first you know with the APK
deal thing going on and I think that we
can you know really agree that this is
not good for PlayStation not even a
matter of like content it's just a
matter of money wise because now you
know they're going to be low-key funding
their own demise in a way because
they're gonna get they're going to be
giving Xbox money to reinvest into their
own ecosystem
now I would say for a little bit there
won't be a lot of reinvesting because
that kind of money they're gonna want to
you know get as much of the pie as
possible but sooner or later you know
not only are you giving them money but
you give them so much bargaining tools
you know for instance after the 10-year
deal what happens you know does Mike and
and Playstation never signed a 10-year
deal they still haven't signed it yet no
so
my question dirt is that Dill even on
the table anymore
I I think it is I think it's still on
the table because um XBox listen man uh
Xbox still would like to get some of
that revenue from PlayStation when it
comes to cot
I think the deal is still on the table I
think it will be on the table
now a PlayStation is refuses to sign it
now that's one thing but I think the
deal would be on the table until
PlayStation signs it unless like I said
unless they refuse to sign it because
you know
um PlayStation makes a lot of money off
of pod and Xbox would benefit from that
even though I do believe
um when the marketing goes to Xbox when
Cod is able to be in Game Pass it will
dip into a PlayStation
um High Revenue I really do believe that
but I don't think it will completely
so let's say okay we're gonna give you
the 10-year deal we try to give you and
you you cause this whole this whole
thing to go down but not only we asking
for this 10-year deal
now we're asking for 80 of the profit we
only get 20. like things like this is
possible yeah absolutely because
PlayStation wouldn't really have a
choice just like Xbox didn't have a
choice when Bobby kotec told them yo we
want 80 you guys can have 20 Xbox didn't
have a choice
now they're going to repackage that it's
it's like it's like Phil Spencer got the
the package where he opened it and to
just throw it out like a bunch of
confetti and it says you're screwed it's
like you opened it up and then he reads
the note it says now you're paying this
uh now now we're only giving you 20 not
30. it's like they're gonna repackage
that Mel instead of the chip Ryan like
exactly exactly but see and that's why
Jim Ryan really didn't want Xbox to own
them because he knows once they own them
there's some things some leverage that
they previously had because they are the
market leader with Activision Blizzard
they're not going to have that same
leverage now the Xbox actually owns
activism blizzard
yeah and not to mention and cod is very
important to PlayStation we all know
that just in general when it comes to
bargaining you know that Call of Duty is
a huge thing to bargain with it's a
massive thing to bargain with and
I'm kind of curious if my if Sony does
back off on all the money that they were
throwing around in that ecosystem
because now if you look at it from a
standpoint they're never going to get
the marketing rights again
and
there's no more exclusive content no
more I don't think people look does
exclusive sell consoles yes
it I think people confuse why consoles
fly off the shelves to a console and
identity you know when you have a Halo
an unchartered a Last of Us a gears that
is what defines a consular identity
that's not with sales consoles that is
what gets the people to choose one over
the other but that's not the definite
reason one is chosen over the other I
am willing to bet you
that marketing does for like Madden 2K
you know Call of Duty those so probably
double to Triple the amount of consoles
than any exclusive would ever do
absolutely with the exception of
Nintendo of course but yeah yeah as far
as Xbox and Playstation oh yeah we know
casual sell um exclusives how many
people do you know in your personal life
that has a tonsil whether it's Xbox or a
PlayStation and all they buy is like
Call of Duty or Madden or 2K like I know
several guys that that's all they buy
you know Call of Duty Madden 2K every
year to be honest with you I know a lot
of people in the chat might not agree
and keep in mind I can't see a lot of
the chat because I have that fan funding
thing on so I can make sure I get the
super chats
I don't see the basic chat so you know
dirt sees any nice little things in
there we could talk about that's fine
but you know when you look at something
like
Ace an exclusive that's so consoles I I
do see The Last of Us I think that was a
defining factor in the gaming industry
but a lot of the games I'm gonna be
honest with you Halo 3
Gears of War 3
those
those are the only two incidences I know
that people went out and bought 360s and
PS3s for it like I think Spider-Man is
one though Spiderman I'll give them
Spiderman yeah I don't think it's
Spider-Man as well I don't think Xbox
has had one yet like as far as like I
think they got one next I think they got
one in two months oh you Starfield you
think Starfield yeah it depends on what
start if Starfield has even a fraction
of what
the uh the Cadence that happened with
Skyrim I could see that happening
because people yeah people don't realize
how popular Skyrim was back in the day
yeah Skyrim was extremely popular and
people loved that franchise to this day
that's the only game I can really
besides like maybe Resident Evil 4. it's
the only game I've bought more than
twice I've bought Skyrim and residue
before probably on every platform known
to man I bought it on you know I bought
the the upgraded version on Xbox series
X you know the one that they just
released not too long ago that might
have been on the original Xbox I don't
know I bought
I got my hands on the 360 version I
bought the Xbox the all the Resident
Evil even the really bad yeah if you go
back sorry my cat's here but if you go
back and you look at the Xbox One
version of
of Resident Evil
it's like really annoying because the r
isn't capitalized in the E I don't think
are like if you go look at the actual
game and I know it's not supposed to
bother me but it does like go go right
now and bring up the X not you I'm
talking to the chat and bring up Xbox
360 Resident Evil 4.
and I kid you not the r and the E of
that title is NOT capitalized and to
this day
it picks up my title screen that you
know the name of the console it says
Resident Evil and and the E and the r
isn't capitalized
um
so I I thought that was some some funny
information and I know they could have
fixed it by now I don't think they have
though all right so
PlayStation response to APK let me get
these super chats real quick oh you guys
are ridiculous uh Jamar Lee with the two
dollar super trade guess what addict
these nuts I don't know why he said that
all right Nintendo the Donna talk with
the two dollar Super Chat say this in
Black addict I don't have a black I'm
white I don't have a black accent uh
fine I'll switch out for the angry
therapist indeed the line was held and
the deal won't be as sweet as the first
offer I would agree it's like I said
that's even if the deal is there I don't
even know what the deal is going to be
there two dollar search for John Wolf
Xbox got 99 problems but I think one out
of no clue what he's talking about
referring to there all right
he's me he's talking about Lena Khan
anymore yeah all right so
dirt should should PlayStation respond
to the ABK do by buying like act uh by
buying like Square Enix maybe Capcom
because they have a good relationship
with them should they
purchase a a company like that in
response to the APK though
sure I mean a Square Enix is the only
realistic one I can see the only
realistic publisher Capcom I think is
out of their range and Capcom is doing
so great for themselves right now why
the hell would they sell to Sony you
know what I'm saying not Square Enix is
the only realistic publisher because
they're
you know they're not doing that great
right now and you know
go to Sony but
I I think that would help I think that
would make the Fanboys happy
I don't think PlayStation really needs
to buy Square Enix because hell man they
already got them
that's like marrying your living
girlfriend after 17 years I mean you
already got her
that's that's how I feel but I mean
more Fanboy console war purposes sure
that I'll help but it's not bigger than
activism blizzard so it is what it is um
but PlayStation they're still going to
buy some more Studios
but like I said the only possibility I
can see is a square units how come I
think is out of their range
I think they could buy either one of
those companies but uh it's like I said
it's easy to get Capcom yeah it's easier
to talk to a
investing investors and talk to board
members Executives and you know just
pretty much anyone in the Microsoft
ecosystem that has a lot of power in the
company and convince them that yo we got
like 80 billion just sitting in here in
cash like inflation's messing with it
it's probably better if we invest it now
before the value of the dollar goes down
it's easier to convince that than it is
to go to the same investors that would
be at Sony and say yo we got to borrow
money
because that at that point you owe
people money
it's not like Microsoft I know in the
past they've done you know uh you know
stock deals and stuff but they bought
Activision with pure cash
that's a lot easier because sure if
Microsoft and XBox doesn't do what
initially they want that service to do
that's on Xbox and Microsoft
but if Sony goes out and borrows all
that money and scoring Enix doesn't
return how they think it is that could
potentially screw the company up
so it's a lot easier to because they got
the equity they they got the IPS they
could easily raise that money
but are you going to convince board
members and stock investors
to go with that and I don't know if that
is easily the case I think I think you
will be shut down on multiple ways
see but this is the thing Square Enix
what is the investment I mean when when
Xbox bought zenimax they have amazing IP
you understand you know Doom Fallout
Skyrim Starfield amazing new IP
Wolfenstein they have some IPS
not Square Enix of course they have
Final Fantasy they have or Star Ocean
um they sold off the rice the Tomb
Raider and some other um titles
what do they have
that really interests Sony
Final Fantasy is already exclusive
Final Fantasy 7 remakes are already
exclusive
what does Square Enix have that Sony
will be willing to go out there and
spend I don't know six seven billion on
bone stars or they get they already got
that exclusive so it was like what what
IP is worth even with Activision
Blizzard we all know mobile is the is
the biggest piece of this whole thing
so what what why would Sony really buy
screenings
I think it's more about
locking down IPS and companies than
buying it for like content because
obviously they still own it
if they bought it would still stay
exclusive I think it's more about making
sure that a Microsoft doesn't get
because imagine if they don't buy Square
Enix or you know Capcom I don't think
capcom's happening either like you said
I think Square Enix is the better choice
it would be really I'd be really pissy
by Sega I'm not gonna lie I'd be really
pissy if they boss Sega would make more
sense to me I'd be really pissy by Sega
yeah
I still have this internal dream that
we're going to see Microsoft Xbox and
Sega in that you you know those pictures
they post when they buy stuff I still
have a dream that we're gonna see Sega
next to Xbox on that thing
hey hey you know what Jamal Lee and uh
Chad just had something he said
something
PlayStation
they're going to games as a service
route
Square Enix what does they have I mean I
know they had outriders but
what do they have that's games as a
service and you know actually
you know one of the Lords I'm not going
to say which one uh he put you guys
could probably not I'm not gonna even
say nothing uh the someone put a topic
because we how IOP functions is we all
bring our own topic to the table every
week
um and one of our topics is Sony
investing 2.1 billion dollars in gaming
r r focused on live Services yeah so
Square Enix doesn't make sense at it
let's be real Square Enix doesn't make
sense the only thing I can now I can
obviously be wrong but the only thing I
could see Sony doing next is buying some
studios some more Studios that can make
us a game for them
I don't screen it's their pedigree is
single player games they're pedigrees
jrpgs do you think that
they're going to because to me it looks
like
it's okay to focus a little bit more on
games as a service because you were
lacking it for so long
but correct me if I'm wrong and maybe
you see it differently but I don't see
this as them focusing a little bit more
on games as a service to me it's looking
like the focus of the whole company on
that
like they're not and that doesn't
necessarily mean they're not going to
focus on you know single player games
anymore
but it's concerning when you're looking
at that and they're they're talking
about by the time
it was like what 2026 or seven they're
going to be spending like 70 percent of
their budget on on you know games as a
service
um
if that's the case back to my original
Point screenings doesn't make sense if
they're moving in that direction
unless phone stars is about to be a
banger addict
you do make a good point once if they
like popped out and got something like
Ubisoft
now Ubisoft will make more sense
if they want to go in that direction
imagine I couldn't imagine kids smooth's
reaction if they bought you yourself
because he actually likes Ubisoft I
don't care me too why don't you be
softball I don't mind their games but
they're not like high on my priority
list but if they came out but you'd be
so I could just see Smooths like right
like I could see a vein just going down
his head right now but you know I like
Ubisoft also I love the Assassin Creed
game I love division
I like assassins I mean I like Ubisoft
also so that would make more sense if
you think about the way PlayStation is
headed Square Enix doesn't make sense to
me
I feel like yeah I think it's just one
of those things where it's like we gotta
actually see it I personally feel like
if they can get Square Enix for the
cheat because score Enix did sell their
Western divisions that was some of the
money gone for them
like for 4 billion you think it just
depends on how much they value Final
Fantasy you know are they going to be
able to sell Final Fantasy at the
highest peak of value to them because
at that point
who else would pay that premium money
besides PlayStation so they even be ever
going to get that kind of money from
them this is like because they come to
them like we want to sell you our
company it's like
but you have put all your value into us
like you can go to you can go to Xbox
but where you put your value so much
into us and all your games are exclusive
Xbox might tell might tell you that the
brick ain't worth it
because
we don't make as much money on your type
of games over here
and
all of your brands at this point is very
well known with a PlayStation
Association
so it's like I'm kind of curious if they
could even get that kind of money all
out of PlayStation out of Xbox
hmm
yeah Square enemies will make no sense
for Xbox besides just buying you know
the IPS score even expects no sense for
Xbox
an Xbox bot Square Enix imagine Twitter
uh like we thought Activision got some
people upset but imagine some of these
PlayStation Fanboys if we woke up in the
morning and they bought Square Enix and
they're yanking Final Fantasy uh rebirth
off of PlayStation and so Xbox only game
like yeah like imagine and then if I was
placed that if I was Xbox and I did that
I would go first I would go further dirt
I'd come out there and say we're
delaying everything six months to a year
well why are you doing that because
there's no Xbox versions so when we cut
the PlayStation versions now they got to
build the Xbox versions from scrap it's
not gonna take a whole lot of time but
it's going to delay the game three to
six months well why don't you just
release the PlayStation version because
it ain't yours anymore like
it did I know that's being but I'm a
petty person right now man you know how
many times people have came at me on
Twitter for this Activision deal thing
like a ridiculous amount like an absurd
amount that's why I like when it comes
to them you know retaliating
there's not a lot of options they really
have like realistically unless they're
going to buy like smaller Indie
developers or double A Studios or
independent Studios I guess they're all
the same thing but it's like you know
maybe remedy but here's the thing like
if they went out and bought like Remedy
or maybe I'll interactive and got some
of these smaller you know independent
developers to nurture them when are you
going to realistically see the the
fruits of that labor it's going to be
years
that's why it would make more sense to
go out there and buy like a cap call and
a Ubisoft or Square Enix for PlayStation
I will agree with you like if if they're
100 going in that direction when it
comes to games as a service versus
single player stuff it would make more
sense for a Ubisoft it would make more
sense for that because the work's been
done like people be acting like well
Microsoft didn't nurture these these
Studios who would who would want to
like do you think they wanted to nurture
the stuff they have now do you think if
you could have went back and had like a
magic wand and said Pay me money and
I'll make sure your people hit the way
they supposed to
they're gonna say no no we want to do it
we want to do it organically dirt we
want to make sure these things make
sense for us
everyone wants a sure thing and when it
comes to building something up look look
could Microsoft when I buy the io buy
the remedy you know bought a couple more
smaller Studios like an ember labs and
stuff like that and like nurture that
how long that two three games before you
start seeing like really consistent
quality stuff with them because it takes
more than just going out and buying a
studio takes years of nurturing sure
Microsoft should have done that in the
360 and the Xbox One air yes they they
didn't
it's over those errors are are long gone
we're not getting that time frame back
the next best thing is to buy Studios
you were working with and you know
what's going on that's why they bought
Bethesda they they literally have
interviews we're taught Howards to the
first person he called when Fallout 76
happened the way he did was Phil Spencer
because they had a relationship you know
I would say ABK is more of a of an
industry move
active Bethesda seems more of a
we've been working together so long I'm
gonna put the ring on the finger move
you know ABK seems like okay we need
something big to go in Game Pass yearly
to consistently get people into the
service that's why I feel like they're
getting ABK we need to do more of a of a
mobile market we also need to do more of
a um
of of a PC market blizzard what's funny
is literally every part people don't
realize how big APK is every individual
letter in those in that company is a
publisher and they all came together and
made a giant publisher
I you could Pro You could argue that no
other company has done something like
that quite like that you can maybe argue
like
you know the THQ Nordic stuff going on
uh you know that that's in in a in a
lead by itself to a large degree and I I
would I would agree with you to a point
but as far as like Activision Blizzard
and King there's very few
scenarios where three big Publishers
have came together and formed like
Phantom Scotland right right and
Microsoft came in there it just did like
like the salt get meme it's like just
started sprinkling that money and took
all of them yeah it's crazy man if you
really think about it
we're we're coming towards the end of it
but you really think about it it's crazy
man um
you know some of the reactions I've been
seeing on Twitter
you know people still saying well
Microsoft they're buying stuff instead
of you know growing their Studios
organically you know what you were just
talking about and I I say this all the
time and Xbox should have done it in the
360 generation 100 but they didn't so
they still have to compete right they
they should have done it they didn't how
many things in our life we wish I wish I
would have done that I wish I would have
worked out more in my 20s right I I
didn't so I have to figure it out now
right and you know it's funny dirt you
can use that same logic and throw it
back at Spider-Man they've had
Spider-Man for 10 15 years it feels like
why didn't they nurture that they they
let Spider-Man make like 15 okay mid
liquid ass games liquid warm ass games
they never brought Spider-Man onto their
own Studios and nurture that that Talent
from their own company but they did it
it's like look like people always
Overlook Spider-Man like that's not a
huge advantage that they don't own
like they went and and I'm convinced
that when Spider-Man was about to get
yanked off of the uh the Marvel world
back it was like a couple years ago
that's when the Wolverine popped up it
was like look like we're not gonna sit
here and just keep doing this back to
back thing you know we want this and
because we because you guys were stupid
and gave us the rights of Spider-Man
years ago as long as we use them let us
play let's let's fool around with the
games you know and I personally feel
because uh Sony is famous for being that
kind of well we're going to we're okay
if other people have we just don't want
Microsoft to have it I wouldn't be some
people are like oh why because we're
about to talk about Black Panther in a
second you know I personally feel like
if if that was a possibility
Xbox would have done something with
Marvel why now I don't think it's a
possibility I think Indiana Jones was
enough out of the the circle that was
probably I don't think I don't think
Sony could really do anything about
Indiana Jones and and not to mention
it's not a Marvel property so and it was
already negotiated with Bethesda before
Microsoft bought them I think if
Microsoft walked in to the Marvel camp
and said we want to make an Iron Man a
Black Panther game they would look at
them and say we legally cannot let you
hmm
probably right
um
yeah but last point you know before we
move on I did want to say that like you
mentioned um they didn't do it in three
seasons generation that they're doing it
now
they're able to do it now it is what it
is those guys need to get over it
because they will be fine if Sony was
throwing it 100 100 let's get these
super chats man two dollars per shot
from the angry therapist why buy Square
they already they're already in Sony's
bag and it's like I said they don't need
School uh Square Enix but you don't know
when someone else it might not be
Microsoft Word for all we know you know
take two decides they want to be more
active in the publishing Universe active
as you can do you can see Google picking
up because a lot of a lot of
Square Enix game work very well on
mobile
besides like Final Fantasy 7 like a lot
of their older catalog they could do
that you know they make a lot of smaller
titles that could easily fit on mobile
so that might be something that they
easily do and you know if like a Google
or a you know a variety of people could
pick up scorings they can't just be
Microsoft Microsoft is a candidate and I
would say that I'm confident because I
made a video it's actually right here
it's this video here
I'm convinced they already was almost
about to buy square units because
they're we've talked about it there's
just a lot of things about
that whole scenario that just does not
make sense to me
um uh two ostrich I've had leave uh for
Sony's ghost EA makes the most sense I
actually I agree with Gregory at the
Ubisoft makes the most sense and
Sony if they're gonna go and they're
gonna put that kind of money
what is if you really think about it
Dirk
besides like Dragon Age
Mass Effect
Dead Space
and like some small knits and knots that
that EA owns what do they really offer
you
a lot of their stuff is licensed
a lot of us thought yep that's that's a
fact that a lot of their stuff portion
of the big Heavy Hitters
from EA's license
so even if you bought the company you
got to negotiate with these companies to
make that and and keep in mind that is a
nightmare people that's the reason you
don't see like a like a baseball game
that's just that or or another Madden
game obviously that has a lot to do with
you know the licensing and stuff but I
think a lot of that has to do if people
aren't throwing money out to stop that
deal
if someone was taking that stuff
seriously and they went to NBA they went
to NFL and they made a deal with them to
to to make it more fair with that that
Madden deal I think that that would open
more doors but if no one is hitting on
the doors
because they're like look like we don't
want to deal with all the teams we don't
want to deal with none of that you know
I think the only company that might want
to do if it's 2K and they're making so
much money off of you know uh NBA 2K why
would they ever mess with that like yeah
see those sports games also added like
you said the licensing yeah it's crazy
years the years back uh some some years
back I remember when NBA 2K renewed
their license with the NBA
bro it was like two billion dollars or
something so it was like I'm not sure
how many years but it was like two
billion dollars if I'm not mistaken so
you see like damn that's why they
monetize their game like they do because
those licenses are super expensive man
and they're constantly changing and not
to mention it's constantly changing
we're talking about the licensing for
like the football players the teams the
stadiums now you talk about the music
school players yep now the music in the
game and if you got some some hall of
fame or some older players you gotta
negotiate individual deals with them or
their estate if they're dead you know
you have to negotiate all that stuff man
those those licenses are a pain in the
ass and that's why I personally feel
like no one's knocking at the doors
trying to get these football like I I
honestly feel like NFL
gave to EA those licensing and no one's
really fought them to to get those more
shared out to everyone yeah because
everyone doesn't want nothing to do with
the 2K is probably the only company and
I bet you throughout the years because
they're making so much money off
everything else they probably only want
nothing to do with the Madden title
anymore like making a football yeah bro
they're so I don't remember back in the
PS2 original Xbox days or even the PS1
days there were so many different
football games NBA games Hockey baseball
remember EA you used to make it pretty
damn good
baseball game uh MLB game then when 2K
had temporarily got the license
they stopped making baseball games and
and when PlayStation got the license
they just completely stopped making
baseball games EA said it's not worth it
they're going to do it so so they just
recently let the FIFA name go
like the name America's feet bro FIFA
was asking for some crazy amount of
money just for the name so EA said the
hell with you guys we're going to this
call it what's called
that's yay we Face the biggest selling
sports game every year but FIFA was they
were like yo you gotta if some crazy
amount of money if anybody in the chat
knows what FIFA is that Meme with Dr
Evil I want one million billion dollars
yeah it was something like that man the
EA was like oh hell no you're not no no
you're not gonna no you're not gonna do
that so they made whatever it's called
not FC or whatever it's called
all right so we're going to go ahead and
uh finish these super chats real quick
and then move on we won't talk about the
Black Panther game too long because I do
want to branch that into Xbox thing but
I do want to talk about what our
expectations were be for our black
panther
um we got a member chat uh from dub17
months over a little over a year Matt
appreciate the member chat
um with how big this latest acquisition
is is it really possible for Xbox to
grab another publisher like Sega with
that extreme scrutiny I don't think
they'll ever buy someone as big as uh as
Activision Blizzard and King gun I don't
think they'll ever buy anyone as big as
no like as far as like the big
Publishers they'll never touch a major
league publisher well who's people on
the same size a little smaller I would
say eae I would say uh take two
I would even put Ubisoft in that degree
to a point like yeah yeah these these
multi-billion dollars
foundations of publishing units oh yeah
oh yeah
like anything above 10 billion dollars
they'll never touch again but I agree I
agree because the thing is the reason
people had their hand out is because
when it comes to this amount of much of
money that's being circulated every
country around the world wants their
peace what are you gonna do for me they
went out and bought a Sega for a couple
billion I think they would let that
slide that wouldn't be too much but if
they had went out there and they tried
to but even escort Enix might be because
you might have to pay Square Enix like
seven eight billion dollars maybe even
more than that I don't know how much
their market shares these days it'll be
worth more than Zenni Max
someone tell someone look right now with
the market value for Square Enix is
currently I don't know I'm just throwing
out numbers
value on the Final Fantasy name but then
again they bought they bought the The
Fallout franchise the Doom franchise the
Wolfenstein franchise and the Elder
Scrolls franchise for like eight billion
dollars yeah I can't see screens being
born as any match but I heard someone
say this I don't know how true it is but
if a uh an acquisition is under 5
billion it doesn't have to go through
the regulatory process
I don't know how true that is but that's
what I heard it's like if it's under 5
billion I wonder if they don't have to
go I want they don't have to go through
the regulatory process I wonder if they
were like yo can we give can we can we
give you like 4 billion in the rest and
like assets or something
that's crazy uh oh hey um live Supremacy
said the FIFA wanted to charge EA double
the amount amount 1 billion every four
years for that license that's a double
wow
aea
all right EA's ability to monitor what
that's crazy bro yeah they're getting a
little bit too crazy with that stuff we
got ten dollars subtract from bulk
everybody forget Activision bought Hawk
Spider-Man Guitar Hero licenses bought
blizzard uh bought King and they bought
called IP and infinity War all
acquisitions Just Like Mike
I agree I agree uh clearly I didn't know
they bought the Spider-Man license maybe
they bought like using the license for a
certain amount of time something
happened where Marvel was able to give
those license to
yeah they were just publishing those
those games those movie games five
dollars subtract from rubber knob it
will actually be even harder for Sony to
buy a large publisher like use yourself
than it was from Microsoft they could
become in a monopoly yeah you know it's
crazy you can even make more of a
argument because Microsoft bought
because Microsoft's bought to buy ABK
that he is 100 right now when a company
like Sony goes out to buy like a Ubisoft
they're like okay now with
with ABK gone it would slowly start to
be looking more more like a monopoly I
to be honest with you even if if Sony
went and bought a company like
like
um like Ubisoft I still wouldn't
consider a monopoly like they're there's
still a lot now I would say that's more
consolidation but like I said from the
start you know you go you go out and I
don't know how you feel about the start
you got you look at a prominent company
that is growing that is doing the right
things sure they have mixed mess-ups and
hiccups what company does it they're
doing everything they're supposed to you
buy them I'm concerned I'm upset because
I feel like you could have stopped you
you might have stopped their trajectory
you might have you know put your finger
in the cookie jar and stop what made
them them
but buying like a UB software they've
pretty much rinse and repeated all of
their games over and over again and
buying like an ABK where a lot of people
maybe not necessarily blizzard and Keen
but Activision especially are feeling
like they're uh the repetitiveness in
their games and you don't really see the
will and the want to change anything
that's what I'm like okay maybe
some change in leadership and change in
ownership is good for the industry
I agree
all right so uh from ten dollar
Superstar from an anonymous boss
salute dirt and addict just like you
said Microsoft just pumped out 70
billion that's a whole lot of money
though don't forget Sony still has loads
of ips don't forget Wolverine yeah I
think they they're able to really
negotiate their with Marvel to get those
IPS I I honestly think people don't
realize the strength in bargaining chips
that Sony has with those Spider-Man
movie license and as long as that
Spider-Man movies license can brain
Marvel a bunch of money don't get it
twisted I'm convinced they would let
them make all the exclusive games and
just shut Microsoft out from every
Marvel IP I think because that's how
important Spider-Man is to Marvel
I agree with you now the thing is this
though
there's clearly been a uh
like the superhero movies let me finish
this because we'll jump straight into
the Black Panther one all right nerds
and other Legends most of the most of
these companies are financially healthy
but I hear embarration group is not they
could be up for grabs and they have a
large portfolio I would actually say
buying embrace your group
would be good for talent and IPS you
know like have you ever looked how much
stuff embrace your group owns in terms
of bunch of them all the old games that
had like the one and duns or had like
two games and we haven't heard like
mercenaries and stuff like they want all
of that person
I used to like mercenaries man
all right so let's let's get into this
black panther so apparently EA's making
a Black Panther game you know first off
I want to talk a little bit about Black
Panther then we're going to go into Xbox
in in the comic book here on Market
because I do feel like they're they're
severely lacking in this department and
I I feel like the longer they wait the
harder it's going to be to bounce back
in this so first up I want your opinion
on what you would expect from a Black
Panther game
and you can use other games to compare
it like a gameplay from one game maybe a
story from one game uh feel free to do
whatever you want in terms of comparing
yeah well I'm expecting um
some fighting mechanics similar to
Arkham Knight you know around there or
Mad Max or something like that
um I'm expecting a a pretty cool game
and I'm not sure exactly what's I mean
it has to be a brawler right because
what else could it be there's not going
to be a shooter right so I'm expecting a
brawler I'm expecting again to be fun
um
we don't know much about it so that's
all I can just go by man you know
I'm expecting
a lot of uh what you call a parkour
climbing on stuff
been able to hop around you know jumping
around on cars maybe something like that
I'm expecting it to be cool though
the Studio's new so we don't really know
in terms of what they've worked on in
the past before or anything like that
I would actually really like
kind of a Shadow of Mordor filling maybe
not necessarily the Nemesis system
because that belongs to Warner Brothers
and it's been uh it's been
copyrighted for some reason I don't know
why the government let them copyright an
engine but that's besides the fact so I
think that
the biggest thing I want from this whole
thing is just solid combat
solid
a solid story
and I just want good graphics you know a
combination of all three of those
because of how beloved this character is
I don't want no like choices like I kind
of feel like just give us a story that
can make it linear it's not a linear you
know sometimes like look at gears five
or you could choose between two people
dying at the end I don't want no choices
like that it's like just give me a story
and tell me the story don't ask me to
tell you the story because when it comes
to Comic Book Heroes in general and
especially Black Panther
you know people are going to want a
story that's going to be grounded and I
feel like the moment you give the input
to the player it just falls apart
yeah
um
yeah I understand what you're saying um
but I guess I just don't know what to
expect you say shadow Mordor I enjoyed
enjoyed that game
you know Mad Max had great hand-to-hand
combat Batman Arkham series
not so much we got them Knights I mean
it was similar but not as good
um so I don't know man um I think it's
I'm looking forward to seeing the game I
still think it's way far out
um but just to know that they're doing a
and I believe it's going to be
multi-platform
Black Panther game I think that's pretty
cool because I don't know if you
remember
the Avenger game they had a black
panther
uh DLC or something or whatever black
panther was and I played it with the
Black Panther it was no different than
the other you know players but that was
that was crystal Dynamics The Avengers
game
but uh I don't know man I just don't
know what to even think about it but I'm
actually hyped that they're making the
Black Panther game though
all right so
let's let's talk about Xbox and and
Comic Book Heroes in general you know
clearly we're not getting Wolverine
Spider-Man most likely black panthers is
a multi-plate they've probably already
announced that
so
do you think that
as long as black pants is good
third-party comic book games can fill
the void of not having Xbox have their
own or do you think that
black panther isn't good enough or you
know if they make an Iron Man game
afterwards that's not good enough that
they need their own
intellectual properties their own IPS to
drive people to the system because of a
comic book because I think right now
with just Spider-Man Spider-Man 2 is
going to come out it's going to you know
Captivate a lot of people but I do think
when you start seeing Wolverine pop out
and if it does well and then let's just
go beyond that let's say they get
another one maybe the Fantastic Four
and then that pops out I think
that's when it's going to be too late
like if Microsoft is going to combat the
comic book games
they gotta do it now and not later
that's a great point that you just made
because right now I feel like it's just
Spider-Man you know Dennis Wolverine
eventually now if if it becomes
PlayStation constantly is is releasing
more and more exclusive superhero games
then I agree with you then that's where
we say Okay Xbox you guys should have
made a move because I remember when they
announced Wolverine initially in 2020 or
was it 2021 2021 where they announced
Wolverine
I remember seeing um some Xbox channels
lose their mind like Xbox you need the
superhero game damage so
if they announce another exclusive
superhero game yeah that would be at the
no you would be at the point of Xbox man
I should have you know we do have
Indiana Jones but that's not a superhero
game
um so
I would like you know maybe eventually
but at the same time like I was about to
say earlier
the superhero phenomenon started to
dwindle a little bit daddy it is I don't
know if you've been noticing especially
the movies because I feel like the the
games are just as popular as the movies
and I think the movies are starting to
do a little down so the games are going
with it
absolutely because we have some
superhero games that didn't do well the
Avengers
The Gardens of the Galaxy didn't do well
there's another one I'm thinking of I
can't think of recently that didn't do
that great or you know so
Spider-Man will still do well even the
Spider-Man movie whenever they make
another one that one will do well but I
just feel that
maybe they're starting to fade a little
bit and maybe this conversation
is something in the future that might
not mean as much as it does now you know
what I'm saying
um because you know I would agree with
you that you know the fading is
definitely there I think the thing I'm
worried the most about is the fact that
we might think it's dead now
but we don't know what the movie
trajectory is going to be you know when
the next Avengers comes out and then the
secret Wars I think there's a good
chance that these things just plunge
right back up
and if it pops right back up I would
rather have Microsoft
on the good into the Spectrum than man
what we gonna do like because imagine if
they build their own
MC their own Game MC universe and by the
time it's I don't want Microsoft to be a
DC what years to try to jump in it and
then when they jump in and they do like
really slow jobs like gotta jumping in
now and I think right now with James
Gunn rebooting DC and he's been very
clear that his his lore
is going to be intertwined with games
right now is when you go to them and say
yo
I'm willing to not only pay for the
games but I'm willing to help you with
the movies too
because
even if they just back some of the
movies
it's best for you to make sure those
movies going to come out good because if
you go out there and you put all this
money
into the next you know Spider-Man game
not Spider-Man the Superman game or the
next Batman game and those movies are
trash
it don't matter what you do but
if James Gunn does turn around the DC
Universe in the next five years we start
seeing real momentum shifts and from
Marvel to DC wouldn't you want Xbox to
already be two games in
sure I mean sure
I um I will say this I do think that the
superhero film industry isn't dead it's
just in a small drought drought right
now because nobody cares about
the recent characters they've revealed
in the MCU all of the TV shows have been
cheeks
um DC has been struggling with Black
Adam and the Flash
that upcoming the Marvels movie doesn't
that's not going to do anything so maybe
when they do get back to Spider-Man you
know because the Thor movie wasn't let
down maybe when they get back into the
the characters people know and love you
know a few of them are dead maybe they
will hype Up Get Hype back up but
I see what you're saying um
it's like I agree with you
but I'm not there with the urgency yet
here's my concern too let's say that
Spider-Man Wolverine does really good
and then you see PlayStation hitting up
DC if James gum's first Superman game
movie does really well they're like yo
let me make a Superman game
and then you're going to be in this
situation where I could personally see
them making a deal with like Warner
Brothers or something like that and
buying like Rocksteady or something
because here's the thing like if they
still continue to see a trajectory going
up on these comic book games
I would not be surprised if PlayStation
tries to lock down the comic book Market
in general with games
and it could easily happen just like
that and people sit there and say oh
Comic Book Heroes isn't the issue it's
not an issue now with one damn game on
PlayStation but they start locking down
Batman Flash
Wolverine Fantastic Four and all these
key components all these love franchises
are on one damn platform it's gonna be
an issue
um
it's like I agree with you but not
really
I feel that
even in video games a lot of superhero
video games have flop lately bro
yeah but I just feel that I just feel
that I don't feel the urgency that you
feel I think it would be nice if they
had some exclusive superhero games
but the urgency I is not there for me
um Spider-Man I guess what Marine is
going to be cool
I guess to me I'm looking at what can be
and not what is and I think that's
that's what I'm mainly looking at
because it's like a lot of the times
when you see these companies and you go
over their Origins
they took leap of face early they didn't
take leap of face late
and a lot of the times when other people
start cashing in and you already see
PlayStation cashing in
by the time you decide to jump in on
that on that ship it's too late
and I would prefer Microsoft to at least
have a foot in the door
while they're doing this then never get
on the ship like so you're saying
you want the games to be exclusive even
if if they're multiplats is it okay
okay so now we're getting a little like
iffy territory I would be okay with a
multi-plat for Game Pass
with a Game Pass option
uh no a multi-plat with Game Pass day
one
and if it does well Microsoft has the
option to buy exclusivity for the
franchise going forward
okay
because if you start making prominent
Batman
Flash and let's say they eventually lead
up to like a Justice League game all of
it's irrelevant if it's on Playstation
as well because not only are you funding
your own game you're funding the comic
book game for the competitor you did
this for all from the start in in the
first place
I mean
see what you're saying but I'm not quite
there yet I feel you and and it's like I
said none of this is like dire need none
of this is yeah I do feel like Microsoft
is setting themselves up to be the best
place to play RPGs in a variety of
fashion they're the best place to play
you know sports games rts's and I think
that's their Lane that's what they're
going for
butts
we've seen what Spider-Man does with
2018 miles opened up a lot of doors
we've seen the amount of hype that just
announcing Wolverine with his claws got
with no gameplay
if these two games start doing very well
because apparently they're supposed to
put them together eventually they're
building this kind of emcee universe
I don't want to get to a point
where
they can't compete with that in a like
obviously
I would say PlayStation can't compete
with the multiplayer they would love to
have the games as a service that that
PlayStation currently has I mean Xbox
currently has they would love to have an
Elder Scrolls Online a Fallout 4 and if
they buy Activision a wow in all these
games and I think that
PlayStation would kill to have some of
these IPS that Microsoft has or is going
to have but all I'm saying is if you
have the opportunity
to get on the ground floor
it's going to be a lot easier doing it
now
than doing it in five years when you
feel like you have to at that point
okay before we move on let me say this
one thing
The Suicide Squad Gotham Knights
The Avengers
um Guardians of the Galaxy
even though Suicide Squad hasn't
released yet it's already getting bad
it's gonna be trash yeah so my my point
is is one thing that you you're not
mentioning
Insomniac is a very good developer right
I feel you on that but we've had a lot
of good ones too you know even though
that rock steady is messing up Suicide
Squad they had multiple good Batmans I
would say something right bro but what
was the last Batman game 2015 yeah
I feel you on that but then you you know
you you look at they're making a Wonder
Woman game with the Nemesis engine I
assume that game's gonna be okay because
Shadow Mordor was a good game now
obviously
we don't know but maybe you are right to
see more of the the landscape with comic
books heroes in the next like year
before making that move but like to me
My worry is
PlayStation just trying to become like
the the over-the-shoulder
box uh you know the the third person
over the shoulder box and the place
where you go to play all comic book
games
because I do think those two together
could be a very deadly combination
okay
um this is the last thing I'm gonna say
if Xbox made uh
comic book game and exclusives cool a
superhero game an exclusive cool
but I think um
at the same time
there might be things more important
yeah I agree there's a lot of things
important yeah and it's like I said I
wouldn't say this is like a vital thing
do now I'm saying this is one of the
things where you know let's let's set up
a lunch meeting with James Gunn next
week and just see see if there's
something we can work out in the future
yeah I understand what you're saying
all right um
we gotta find out super trap from black
Ronin let's talk about how it's been
pointed out that t'chanka is that how
you pronounce his name I always [__] it
up
who uh the person that is the original
black panther well it's not the original
one
to challenge me isn't that his name
yeah yeah okay
uh may not be the actual black panther
what kind of buckery is that if it is if
it ain't t'challa
um
yeah I see that that's what I'm saying
like if it's like make your own black
panther like like that
that is weird like bro I said this if
the if the Avenger game
would have just had the actor's license
uh likeness I know it would have been
more expensive they didn't even have the
voice to characters but if they would
have had their likeness that would have
helped that game a lot because even The
Gardens of the Galaxy game I understand
you know like I said it'll be much more
expensive like the Indiana Jones game
I'm expecting them to have hairs before
likeness bro
if it was not Harrison Ford to me that's
like a letdown he doesn't have to voice
the character but Justice likeness I
agree
uh we got a super trap from uh Spartan
ghost 17 please Microsoft bring back
prototype damn it I actually like that
game Prototype was pretty cool that's a
pretty good game
we got a yeah man they're gonna have
some IPS but I don't think they're gonna
do a lot with those IPS though man
that's why if they do pick up Activision
Blizzard King I want them to have their
own Blue Point
because it is yeah it's like have a
studio that is designed to just remake
stuff because older IPS have just as
much value depending if they're done
right absolutely that newer IPS can have
ten dollars Andy MC uh seeing as a rare
is working with lucasart do you see any
other IPS Microsoft and Lucas Disney
could be working on
um not currently maybe it'd be cool if
they picked up like a Star Wars that'd
be cool Like a Star Wars game maybe
Amanda Star Wars game
Star Wars that news Outlaws Star Wars
game looks pretty good from Ubisoft that
game looks pretty sweet to me man
yeah so you know and I think that
even though Marvel isn't Up For Debate I
don't think with Microsoft I do think
Indiana Jones stuff like that Star Wars
that is open and if you can't get that
just do a really good Star Wars game I
don't know I get it I I personally feel
like Microsoft needs to be a little bit
more in the mainstream where they have
more iconic titles on their platform
because I think that really helps uh we
got a two dollars two shot from P lump
uh uh what kind of holdups oh if you got
Spartan goals Spartan goes with the uh
the two uh Super Chat uh manga is
outselling Comics over 100 to one added
and I agree with you but
I played very few good anime games like
very very few I I think I actually
really like the attack on Titan games
and I liked Naruto clash of something I
can't remember it was the 360 game and I
like like a couple of the storms
but that's it fam that's it all these
years of making any uh anime games
that's it yeah uh hey Jeremy Brown he
said he said something I want to say he
said let's not act like superhero games
don't flop it's not guaranteed goal yeah
I I mentioned they the last several has
flopped with the exception of hell I I
was exception of Spiderman I will be
regardless of the Galaxy
but that was a great game but it still
didn't say that's what I'm saying the
other ones flop for other reasons
because they want good games
I think the Avengers wasn't a bad game
it was just it was just it was at the
service it was designed differently than
it was supposed to than it should have
been it should have been a line of your
game
uh from p-lump addict bumped them
comic book games dirt you POS I don't
know come on pre-line attack at me or
you
I don't know probably me peel up you how
dare you Jamar Lee with the two dollar
Superior Sony not talk uh taking no risk
on single player games and service
I I agree I I don't know what they're
going to be doing with those games this
service five dollars from the angry
therapist MD that Adventure game didn't
work for me because Hulk and Thor
fighting regular humans and they getting
back up these should be one shot people
I agree that's true see it's little
things like that like I can't give you
too much that a comic book game didn't
do well when it was made poorly
you know for the most part
like comic book ones that weren't made
alongside a movie or something
they've generally done well besides
Guardians of the Galaxy
but let's get on with the the main event
man let's let's get on with the main
event we we just go man
one hour and 11 minutes so I plan on
talking about this for a couple minutes
because oh it's it's crazy man it's
crazy so
as we know the injunction that the FTC
applied to prevent Microsoft from
closing the ABK Dill has officially been
overruled uh so they didn't get it
and people popping bottles obviously
people should be popping bottles because
this was the biggest platform that the
biggest obstacle Microsoft had and the
obstacle was so big that the moment
the decision came out
the CMA
backtracked and said no we work it out
like because I feel like at that point
the CMA looked and said look there's not
much we can do at this point like we
need to at least make some kind of deal
because we're going to lose all that
money that is generated in our country
off of the games that we're about to
block
and you know shout out to the 570 people
in the chat you know share this on
Twitter man I know I know people don't
like the uh some of the topics that we
were talking about but share it on
Twitter man we bout to get straight into
this and we'll get to the super chats
here in a minute dirt how you feeling
about this man cause uh because we we
celebrating man we celebrate him
nah I love it man um
it's been a long time coming I know it's
not all the way finished yet it's not
official people questioning if the FTC
is going to appeal they're going to
appeal they got a couple days to do it
they better do it before Friday because
Friday is the deadline look man
this thing has been up there's been
upstairs been Downs it seemed like every
time there's been downs from I think
December of 2022 when the FTC sued the
block and people went crazy I remember
PlayStation Fanboys went crazy saying
it's over the deal is dead and then we
heard it's not dead and it went positive
again then a few months ago when the CMA
blocked oh
that was a rough day
that was a rough day ponies was coming
in my chat I haven't seen some of these
ponies in years they were talking trash
and people said excuse me that's it it's
it's dead it's dead
so here we are and I'm gonna give a
shout out to Michael packter
yeah that dude never he never got off
the line bro even when the CMA blocked
it Michael I remember watching him on
Destin or some somewhere else I don't
know where I saw he said he was all no
no it's still going to go through he
said this is what's going to happen the
EU is going to approve the deal
he said the FTC is going to most likely
lose in court then he said the CMA will
try to negotiate with Xbox and come to
some type of deal bro that's exactly
what happened
that's exactly what's going on so
sometimes he you know like with like his
gaming takes are usually off
when it comes to actual gaming but this
type of stuff he knows his stuff
um but yeah this this stuff is very
interesting because like you mentioned
we all know that the FTC
um they were trying to pretty much Stop
Xbox from stop Microsoft from closing
his deal they wanted to prolong the
process hopefully with Microsoft kind of
and walking away from the deal so I'm
glad
that you know Microsoft can close this
deal with the whole you know if the FTC
doesn't appeal which I don't think they
will maybe they will maybe they won't
but Microsoft is one of the closest deal
people are saying by Monday now the CMA
with them now we're hearing there saying
well
we might have to go investigate the
whole thing again I think I think that's
all Bs
I think
they're trying to stall they're trying
to waste some time also but at the end
of the day this deal will go through
um I'm more confident than ever and
let's have some fun bro
let's have some fun
so
there was some some kind of thing leaked
out I can't remember what it was it was
deleted before I saw it it was like some
German website or something that
had the back end
saying Diablo was about to put in Game
Pass did you see yeah I saw that I saw
that yeah Mike Ybarra did come out
openly and deny it
but we've seen over and over again
what's he gonna do came out and say you
know it's coming in Game Pass in a month
or two or however duration it would be
uh don't buy Diablo go out and wait for
Game Pass I obviously until that deal
was officially confirmed and went
through he's gonna protect the interest
of of Bethesda and he's going to try to
make as much money as possible that
doesn't necessarily mean that like Game
Pass would like kill itself it just
means that there would be more people on
the Xbox platform that might wait for
the game to hit game pass that would be
to buy it so
what to me
the best announcement you can have
is announcing
Call of Duty announcing all the Call of
Duty games coming to Game Pass maybe not
the ridge the the new one this year
yeah no no no I don't think that's gonna
happen it can't it can't can't come this
year
so I think that would be the best bet
all those coming to Game Pass and you
know do you think that they space out
all of Activision's games do you think
you know they just put all the ones
that's able to right now gone oh they're
gonna drop it like a like a boatload of
them bro just like they there was any
max remember they dropped all but
there's again 15 of them or something
like that yeah all at once I think
they're gonna do that you know all like
because like don't forget all of the
Call of Duties
from the 360s generation are BC all of
them
just throw them in there not just the
Call of Duty store the crashes and all
that stuff in there man spiral
Spyro oh I'm in there you know Xbox
property now one can argue once they buy
this company
they could easily make their own Super
Smash Brothers type of game
they could bro I think I don't even
think Nintendo makes that I think like
Capcom makes that or something I don't
know people in the in the chat put that
in there let me switch to the chat so I
could see but uh I if you even if you
have to make your own Studio
I don't know because a lot of people's
try to make that and it hasn't been very
successful
and I think that some of them were good
attempts and some of them weren't good
attempts yeah bam damn code makes it so
I think you get some studios you make
that type of game because APK got so
many IPS
spiral crap bethesda's got so many
IPS Xbox got so many IPS you could
easily have your own brawl easily I
imagine selling one versus Master Chief
you know you know would be better and I
know this would never happen
they go over there Nintendo we want to
have a Super Smash Brothers versus our
game or whatever you want to call it
like like Nintendo versus Xbox or
something like that Super Smash Bros man
do you imagine Majesty versus uh Luigi
yeah imagine if they talk to them and
said we will give you access to all of
our IPS to put them in Spanish but you
have to put smash on Xbox
nah they were Nintendo ain't doing that
bro you know how Nintendo and I'm
getting super chat for you Adam Michael
Mooney with the five pounds Lord of the
Rings is the reason for Amazon to have
Warner Brothers Discovery and embracer
group on their shopping list
hmm Lord of the Rings
well what was that game that just
dropped uh the Golem game they said that
game was about okay but we we can't
compare Lord of the Rings to that game
that game was always going to be
underwhelming okay I saw that game of
attacks it was oh so you're inside for
you I was trying not to play that game
because of how like I just had to see
Golem like how crazy Golem looks right
and just think yeah that's not it that's
not it I don't I don't understand who
looked at that game and and greenlit
that game who's the publisher of that
I have no idea it's probably embrace
your group I don't know why like I think
it is embracing I think it is though
I've got to the point where I see
embrace your group games that I'm just
expecting to it's okay or just be
underwhelmed I mean you didn't like
sayings bro
underwhelmed you know uh I finished it
bro Destroy Humans those are fun so it's
like a fun time embrace your group just
feels like they buy a bunch of ips to
cash out on them and they don't really
try to invest in the IP and make them
better and that's my biggest snack with
them and that's why I feel like
Microsoft's got all these Studios and
they're about to buy ebk like go to
embrace your group and buy a couple of
these IPS and rebrite and rebrake uh
remake them I want them the first thing
I want them to buy from a bracelet is
Crystal Dynamics Idols Montreal
and I think that will happen because
they're already working on Xbox games
anyway
so
oh I like this gmax babe because because
I'm in the live chat now hear me out
playground games Forza kart racing
including all of these mascots
that would actually work that would work
but I get toys from Bob to do it
because they did the crash Rumble see
that game is not going to do well
because crash universe is not come on I
don't even know the only characters I
know is crash in that girl I don't even
know her damn name
so that crash team Rumble is not going
to do well but toys from Bob and tell
you those guys are talented because
brass bandico 4 was amazing I don't know
if you played it that game was freaking
amazing they have the talent to do
something like that bro you know this
banjo and this this God forbid chat took
our Banjo-Kazooie conversation and
attacked me on IOP with it did they yeah
I was not I missed that thrill and we
argued about Crash versus conquer for
like 30 40 minutes man crash for no not
crash Banjo-Kazooie versus calling her
for like 30 40 minutes yeah that's not
really a real discussion addict yes it's
banjo obviously no it's definitely
Congress anyone that wants conquerors
succeed
we have a squirrel getting drunk in a
bar calling his girlfriend to a bear
walking around with a bird in his
backpack which one sounds cooler to you
okay the bear walking around no further
questions
about like the the
the
mineral things that Concord did we're
going to talk about the amazing platform
that was in Banjo-Kazooie it was it was
yeah fine but because
conquer fought poop man
okay I want some poop
and and conquer
come on let's not get it started again
let's not get it started right come on
these people really went to IOP with
that someone went to our patreon they
hijacked it it started that conversation
and me and King argued about that for
like 30 minutes so King was on Concord
side obviously right
everyone is on conquer side except for
you except for you I had a couple people
in the chat that was fighting the good
fight but it seemed like most of them
would want to bury banjo right there
with all the other mascots that no one
likes now I would tell you something you
see like you misspoken you said crash
versus conquer that's a real
conversation right there though that's a
real conversation no it's not because
conquer is trash okay
two dollars per shot from Corey Tidwell
Master Chief would beat the brakes off
Luigi easily bro that's why I said it
like imagine marriage with Chief versus
Luigi look like one one guy has a vacuum
[Music]
you have to be our rifle come on man
it's over I just uh I think when it
comes down to like this APK deal thing
I think after this they're gonna cool
down for a little bit but I think
they're gonna go They're gonna pick
straight back up where they were right I
honestly do they're gonna pick straight
back up where they were
I don't think they're even close to
being ready and I think they
they they gonna take this straight to
the promised land like and I'm curious
because they had to go through so much
turmoil
they do leave because did you see the
judge said that everything else not Call
of Duty could be exclusive and it
wouldn't affect the market yeah I did
see that I did see that
I did see that well you know we already
kind of heard uh even though it wasn't
confirmed but we kind of heard that
future new IPS is going to be exclusive
from blizzard Activision from from
Activision Blizzard so um I don't know
if they and we heard they're making a
few new IPS
imagine this like Diablo
5 was an XBox exclusive
ah
I don't think they would make Diablo an
exclusive uh an exclusive but I think
the next crash that that suck is an
exclusive the next you know what that
suck is an exclusive there's a lot of
things I thought maybe Xbox wouldn't do
but these these this trial
a lot of stuff has come out in the open
and we heard Phil Spencer said they had
discussions about making Minecraft
Legends and also Minecraft dungeons
exclusive they had discussions about
making certain games exclusive that we
thought they would have never thought
about making those games exclusive and
the Indiana Jones thing let's be real at
it
Indiana Jones was being was was going to
be a multiplayer
Phil Spencer said um nah let's go ahead
and all Disney said let's let's
renegotiate make this boy exclusive
so Diablo I'm telling you bro
PC is the biggest market for Diablo
first of all it's going to be on PC
Diablo's five for me like years from now
I don't know but they could possibly
make that game exclusive but who knows
right we don't know really you do have a
good point a good argument I would say
that
there is a chance
um that they would do something like
that I think it all just comes down to
how serious they are in their model
you know I think there's actual a
possibility in the future that they
looked
they lost Call of Duty out of
PlayStation
two years yeah it just that's they even
get a 10 year too I'm not con I'm not
convinced they get a ten year deal at
this point I have a Sony has to sign
that deal bro but they offered Sony that
deal multiple times like at this point
the CMA is just gonna that what what are
they gonna fight you over and if the FTC
don't don't
bringing up any more fight and they just
go down willingly why would they have to
sign that like why would they have to
offer PlayStation that because they've
already went through the entire
Battlefield
I mean from PlayStation's point of view
you better sign is that deal even
available anymore
it's like everyone else signed the peace
treaty before the before like the bombs
started dropping and Sony was like we
got bombs we got bombs too like we we
got easy we got maybe even more bombs
than you and then they decided to bomb
each other and now Sony sitting there
with like half a leg like two fingers
missing he's like can we can we sign the
Peachtree tonight no you can't sign no
peace treaty you had bombs but guess
what Sony
we had more Buzz because we got money
like
let me say this Alex before we get out
of here if PlayStation
let's Xbox pull this deal after the deal
is finalized right if PlayStation lets
Xbox pull this damn deal off the table
because they refuse to sign it Jim Ryan
everybody over there
needs to be evaluated
because remember what Phil Spencer said
when he was under oath he said all right
we are going to keep Call of Duty on
Playstation as long as they allow us he
still say that he said it twice as long
as they allow us
imagine
they're sitting there and they come back
to the table and he's like okay and he's
like he's in like his hands and uh
what's those things called when your
hands up sling a sling he's got like
he's got like one eye on this eye patch
over it like have one of his ears is
gone and he's sitting he's like okay I'm
ready to sign the one year time the
10-year exclusive deal Phil sits down
completely good no no damage at all just
this time was like puts it over there
and he's like okay sign it he looks like
he's like Phil it says five years
well the 10 years was last week still
this five-year deal that's this week's
deal wow and he's like but you offer 10.
now Phil from Phil a couple weeks ago
off for 10. Phil right now offered you
five
okay Phil I I can we negotiate if you
keep arguing I'm gonna put two like
paper
or I have my guards escort you back out
to the battlefield you don't look like
you walked that well right now Jim
do you really want to come back here to
a two-year contract you're funny but you
know what
you're actually right though because I'm
gonna say this if this deal is finalized
and that 10-year deal isn't signed Xbox
has all the leverage in the world bro
because they have the level it's just
like at this point
they had the leverage because they were
trying to silence PlayStation and to
stop Making Waves we're going to give
you this 10-year deal
just shut the hell up
they didn't
not only did they they put a budget
behind trying to stop the deal
didn't work
looks like it's completely been thrown
out
a lot of these people a lot of these
countries agree to with no
consolidations
and now they're in this the final
stretch that's like
stopping and right when you're about to
hit the the finish line
they try to stop you from crossing the
Finish Line I got this whole race
I'm at the
at the Slime what could you possibly
offer me
that doesn't make me go over that Finish
Line because at any time it's looking
like Xbox could just cross the finish
line
they don't need PlayStation at this
point what is PlayStation realistically
has to offer Xbox
to continue doing the 10-year deal
way past when everyone else signed them
people keep forgetting that they offered
Nintendo his 10-year deal Nintendo's
like done
they offer that to to everyone else done
they offered at the place say nah fan
that ain't good enough we don't want the
Call of Duty deal we want to block the
deal so why would they like to come up
there after they've done that's like
that's like
having someone come up there
bombing your whole village and you get
out
and you just drop a spear bomb on them
and then they try to come up there and
they trying to tell you that you can't
they're trying to make you sign the
peace treaty no I have one
we don't sign peace treaties here you
had the opportunity to bend the knee and
now you're gonna get dealt with you get
what I feel you worth like
oh man
funny stuff bro let me see somebody to
say they people saying stop
bomb analogies that's
that's man that's that's my analogy
I have to get five dollar subscribe for
the anger therapist MD can't put games
on PS5 about the dev kits I I feel you
on that five dollars yeah that's true
yeah you can find out super cobweb uh
Phil offered at all all ABK games
including new games through 2028 Sony is
not getting that deal they'll get caught
under the current uh plan nothing else
what happens
so I guess FTC is going to appeal
oh it's out breaking news yeah I guess
they're going to appeal it's like
they're wasting their time bro
I said 90 10 split that they offer them
a 99 one split
wow at that point Sony probably would
not they they would just not accept Call
of Duty because at that at that current
thing they wouldn't be making really any
money uh but yeah yeah it's just
Sony played himself you know I don't
know how I don't know if they'll be able
to like really appeal it to a degree
if they are wasting their time maybe
they're just gonna they're gonna Lobby
the better people to get a ton uh you
know it's been wasting their time bro at
this point it's Sony
they just they need to go ahead and just
just deal with it like you know they
didn't sign the deal and they deal with
whatever consequences they feel that
they're gonna get because at this point
you didn't sign it when it was when it
was 30 a brick
now now you're gonna have to sign it
when it's 10 to break
so you know yeah there you go man I went
from bomb alley uh
bomb analogies to to drug allergy
analogies I hope the chat's happy look
at you reduced me to
I think that's all the super chats
because I think we're gonna go ahead and
close out
yeah I think this uh yep that's it
it was a pretty good show man where the
people catch you at Dirk you've been
going on a lot here lately Matt but see
you you get you breaking numbers man you
know you breaking numbers like
PlayStation dropping bombs
[Laughter]
yeah man it's a lot of fun man um
yo check out my channel guys I just
dropped a video earlier man um
talk about some of the PlayStation
Fanboys in the community you know how I
do it um yeah man it's been this has
been a huge topic
it's been pretty um fun Jamal Lee said
you missed my super
man uh two dollars from Ali
uh what about call uh what about called
Dev per doing horror Halo DLC what about
call of devs doing a horror Halo DLC I
think that's what you mean if not I
don't want
the call devs doing a horde Halo DLC
no yeah as you can call weave level five
uh Bill offered
he's a field offer all ABK you know
exactly new games oh yeah you said field
offer all ABK games including new games
through 2028
somebody's not getting that deal they'll
get high under the current pla nothing
else yeah I got that five dollar shooter
from the character oh my God five
dollars for chat from the Caroline Corps
State guys being very generous man Phil
Kent uh Phil can I kiss some cod please
sure Jim don't mention that one thing
I'm gonna need that Spider Man what's it
what's the field comes out there and Jim
Ryan sits down across the street across
the table and he's like can we have the
deal for sure Phil sure Jim and he lets
him sign and he picks it up and he does
you know that classic stack the paper
thing he just gets up he Stacks the
paper puts his little envelope Phil gets
up walks out the door and does like the
the the one the the stair behind thing
like this and he's like hey Jim we need
that we need that Spider-Man though man
okay he just walks out all right run
that Spiderman
Sony won't provide PS5 Dev kits to
Activision with Microsoft then they just
get less performing games that's their
fault like look I get it from their
perspective they're in the right for
doing that but you can't complain about
less performing games when you're the
one that didn't give them the tools to
do it in the first place yep ten dollars
from Spartan six six one Sony tried to
shut down Xbox All These Years Phil told
Jim uh after putting up with uh his BS
for so long enough Phil was fed up with
it and told him hold my beer after he
bought ABK Phil Spencer said no more now
Phil's done a lot to this man you know
Jim Ryan probably having flashbacks
about Phil Spencer right now yeah just
think about it
and no other console generation has
a person leading PlayStation how to deal
with all of Bethesda games getting
yanked off his platform the potential of
APK deal is getting yanked off his
platform
all right so what I'm gonna do is I I'm
gonna send you guys over there to to
fame I'm assuming he's streaming I
haven't looked yet uh but you know yeah
definitely go go [__] go follow dirt man
there has some very fun content I think
you guys would enjoy it and you know one
thing I want you guys to do I know that
some of you probably don't stay in there
on fame's podcast just stay in there
listen to it a little bit too don't
subscribe TX 1138 Sony has Spider-Man
Xbox has the Hulk with ABK that'd be
cool but I want you guys sitting there
man let's do a couple minutes if you
guys don't have time that's cool just go
in there at least give a like button put
in that chat that the attic show sent
you guys and I appreciate her coming
through anything else dirt we foreign